and you have to like pop it in and the
trick is like keep your hand there and
close it off or it's gonna like explode
everywhere
hi I'm sweaty and I'm representing India
hi I'm cute Oh me and I'm Japanese
hey I'm 10 and I'm representing Indian I
am I go and I'm representing Japan and
we're here today to swap some snacks I
don't know if this is Japanese but I've
had those little Pocky things Pocky
sterics yeah those are Japanese okay so
Indian snacks I don't know too much
about it but um I assume there will be a
lot of spices aromatics I don't know I'm
excited for it cuz I love Indian cuisine
so I feel like today it's treat that
family let's bring on the snacks cuz I'm
hungry
these are water lily pops tikka masala
it's the seed of a lotus this says water
lily and then it's just it's like
popcorn made out of Lotus II imagine
this is just like a Indian pop chip it's
like it looks like a popcorn yeah yeah
it is yeah it is it is kind of like that
I have here mixed crackers I feel like
this is pretty much the Japanese version
of a party mix I am excited
I'm a big fan of ready up I mean I like
Chex Mix and other mixed snacks so oh
yeah these are good this is such a good
like I'm watching TV and I just want
something that's like sweet and salty
this is fire there's a better detective
this is lotus seed no I mean it says
water lily over there but no one calls
him lotus seed salt that's what I'm
calling him you could taste the masala
he was all become I saw I haven't had
this flavored like Airy popcorn like
treat and the fact that these are you
said lily pods right yeah yep Lily see
there they go I've never had lily seed
popcorn oh these are good the tikka
masala flavor is like it's fantastic
I kind of like these guys I mean they're
light and airy I mean they're both nice
and light but this flavor I really like
I'm Dobbs I'm actually gonna go with
these guys right here I'm gonna go with
this for now because this is really good
here we have it's called Afghan opal no
subtle which is like a cute little
whimsical they're little they're bamboo
shoots it's a little cookie with a
chocolate over it wait can you tell me I
pronounce it takenoko takenoko no sato
no sato yeah party no ko is bamboo
shoot'
hide-and-seek cookies I loved these
growing up I still love them now I would
dip them in milk or tea this is one of
the more popular ones and one of the
biggest Bollywood stars ever his name is
Shahrukh Khan
he's like the brand ambassador so you
could think of him as like Indian Tom
Cruise or Indian Brad Pitt in terms of
like how popular he is these were
Shahrukh Khan cookies in my head they
still are but I guess we'll go buy hide
and seek today yeah oh nice oh yeah oh
nice little oh it smells amazing it's a
strong boy mmm this is super light but
it has like that Chips Ahoy kind of
thing mm-hmm oh this would be really
good with chai tea all right so this is
an actual bamboo shoot oh no no no it's
just shaped like a bean oh god I'm
really interested in this on flavor and
texture experience it's very different
than a traditional cookie I feel like
and the chocolate it looks like it
there's not much on it really cause it
looks so thin but it is so flavorful
especially compared to like American
chocolate I grew up on these so this is
nostalgic to me so I'm gonna stay with
that one just a nostalgia like I
recognize this packaging I know the
commercials like I was saying so yeah
how does he I feel like trying new
things there's always fun so this would
be my snack for the moment I think my
decision might be different if I was if
I had like no clue it I have to go with
that
this is maza it's a very popular Indian
mango drink also one of my favorites
it's a classic don't get anytime
anywhere it's a great summer drink it's
great super cold right out of the fridge
if you like mango you will love it it's
not really comparable to anything you
would get in the in the US
um so mine is feminine this bottle is
like classic summer Japanese drink
I always think Japanese fruit flavors
taste different from fruit flavors from
other countries which i think is
interesting and there's actually it says
here like how to open remove the seal
but they have a little glass marble up
here and you have to like pop it in and
the trick is like keep your hand there
and close it off or it's gonna like
explode everywhere remove the seal from
the top detach the plunger from the
center yeah is this a plunger mm-hmm
watch my struggle yeah Wow wait that's
so funny
cheers let's do this this is cool it's
actually uh it's lighter than that like
American soda it's like what I would
want look want to be the Lacroix drinks
it's what I would want them to taste
like that is a good point cuz it's the
it's the flavor but it's light and it's
still carbonated but you can you taste
the flavor it's only recently that I
started to actually enjoy the flavor of
mango and this is very like mango it is
it is really good though it is yeah it's
thicker than your traditional juice I
feel like I kind of like that though
yeah got like a sort of like not really
a smoothie texture but almost there's a
stun just these two items here I'll go a
maza because I'm really into the mango
flavor
I think design-wise ramen a wins but
like flavor-wise
I will go for the maza because I feel
like this has a lot of potential
it'll be great with a cocktail this will
be good for mimosa
every time I'm picking one I feel like
I'm lying because I like them both
equally this is called meteor cider they
kind of taste like soda
they're like kind of carbonated that's
oh good there it's like a carbonated
candy and I don't know if you're a candy
biter but if you bite down it'll be good
is it hard it's a hard candy but there's
a surprise oh okay I like surprises this
is Emily pop it is basically that means
tamarind emily is tamarind and that's a
really popular they use it in like
chutneys and then they also have like
little candies and then this is just I
guess pop form we seen a lot of flavors
they would not expect in candy yeah you
got some chilli cumin jaggery chef
japanese artificial grape is like it
tastes like grape oh I like it it's not
like your Jolly Ranchers
oh Mountain I've seen the melon yeah
this is good was that like what was that
was they gonna liquid that burst it's a
I'm pretty sure this one's a powder
there's a powder okay but it like super
flavored yeah it's like dizzy right yes
supposed to be a carbonated like cider
yeah this is like uh I was giving me
like it's kind of a warhead vibe not
sour but like the texture and the amount
of flavor that's packed in that's
probably weird for your mouth hmm it's
not like this at all just takes a minute
to get you oh that's spicy there is a
spice element there's a sweetness to it
there's like all the flavor is up I
could pinpoint in add it like Indian
dish which is which is great but it's in
snack sweet snack
hmmm I'm gonna go with this once again
it's different it's fun it's fizzy it's
still in my mouth I love it my gold as
well even though I haven't tried them
all
I like the grape flavor better than I
like tamarind so I was using right here
as much as I like this I feel like this
I could eat again every single flavor
multiple times continuously
and give myself a cavity I learned that
you're packaging which I already knew
this but it's so adorable y'all really
think about art it's like eating art
it's so fun that drink was like it was a
true experience to get to the drink the
marble was aesthetic it's all it's like
an aesthetic experience I really enjoyed
all the Indian snacks I got to try today
I feel like I got the spiciness the
sleep the even the chocolate cookie it's
like it's there's something about it
that's nostalgic but at the same time
like I could taste what I would expect
in it in-game cuisine so yeah it was
very well-rounded and I really enjoyed
about we're going grocery shopping after
this yeah that's it
[Music]
you
[Music]